President Trump said he was not happy
with the Oscars did you know that true
story he was furious that Best Foreign
Film went to someone from another
country we gotta fix that it's a cry do
you see that Spike Lee tried to leave
before the show was over and they
wouldn't let him did you see that yeah I
just want to quickly say ladies and
gentlemen we have that same rule here no
sir you'll stay seated because believe
me I've tried yeah they are rough at the
door and he's always trying to get to
his car at the top of this show
the big news though is there was no host
last night no host last night and the
show did better ratings were up 11% so
today people are saying maybe we don't
need a host anymore do you know what
that means to me do you know how
terrifying that concept is all last
night I was like tossing attorney end of
host no hos host on it's like it's like
people don't want your kids to have
jewelry exactly what
kids don't wear jewelry I'll have to
point leap this is my livelihood they're
talking about it isn't totally
everyone's like life's better without a
host without a host the world is pure
anarchy would be absolutely weekend can
you imagine the prices right without a
host it'd be chaos everybody would come
on down
[Music]
the big moment that everyone spent about
today was when Bradley Cooper and Lady
gaga gave that live performance of shall
oh yeah it was it was so intimate I mean
you can see right here there's this
picture here so intimate and then I
think we have another one I mean it was
just yes they were like locked in they
were so close did you see it Annie yeah
I gave me goosebumps I felt like you
know it was like watching a private
moment between the two of them yeah so
it was amazing because it's like the way
they held each other's gazes as they
sang really gave the performance a very
emotional quality yeah and I loved how
they kept inching closer to each other
till their bodies were almost touching I
mean I think the theater probably got 30
degrees warmer just from the heat of
that performance yeah and heat that they
were giving off yeah yeah oh yeah I
talked about selling a song they were
practically having sex with their eyes
yeah you know after that performance all
I could think was
all I could think was fat chance Mary
Poppins returns yeah I had the same
thought mm-hmm so uh what did you do for
the Oscars what was your fun has had a
few people over in a wash it hadn't you
know nachos we treat her like the Super
Bowl having is the same thing just to me
and the wife we have some snacks and I
know we were kiddin before but I didn't
miss having a hostess really was very
happy with all the awards what can you
do I like because after it was over
after the Oscar was over we just we
watched Russian doll on Netflix man I
love natasha Lyonne she's fantastic yeah
well I gotta say honey it's been really
nice talking to you I'm gonna go back to
my stool now all right
you